why do they put against Episcopalians in
parentheses up there because
Episcopalians are what Anglicans are
called in the united states and then we
get further on in the the semester we'll
talk about why they use that name it has
to do the Revolutionary War and the fact
that a lot of anglican is actually
fought on the side that lost the they
will Tories and so they had to prove
their loyalty but we'll get to that
discussion a bit later your book talks
about the Anglican tradition and again
we're talking about a the conservative
or traditional Reformation and it starts
out very very very traditional the only
big change at the very start is who's in
charge and your book talks about sheep
precedence for this the the Spanish
monarchy called a very tight control
over the church in it in its domains you
know the Spanish Inquisition was
something that was not primarily run by
the the you know the Vatican or the the
Catholic Church is such it was something
run by the Spanish crown and you know
they incorporated religious things there
was something called Gallic anism in
France where the French King would say I
get to decide what the bishops are going
to be in the French church should be
more or less independent those kind of
died out in England though there was
this guy we've probably all seen
pictures on he's a big fat guy usually
in like in a lot of a lot of clothes
Henry what number of things a lot of
Henry's Henry the Eighth right and Henry
the Eighth married a lot of people and
back then it was actually pretty easy to
it not fear an ordinary person but if
you were one of the nobility it was
pretty easy if you didn't like the
person that you were married to he had
some power to get a divorce or an
annulment and oftentimes it had to do
like demonstrating that there was
consanguinity and this is a whole story
there that's quite interesting to talk
about long story short Henry wanted to
divorce somebody and it appeals to the
Pope Pope Clement the seven he had
wanted to get out of this marriage of
Catherine of Aragon and she you know she
wasn't he having male heirs that's part
of the things that you want is it as a
king back then Henry was you know ty did
pretty well with the church but the Pope
says no to him and so Henry does
something that for an English monarch he
said the image already had a long
tradition of being sort of
semi-independent he says I'm in charge
he gets Parliament to actually two to
agree to this and he becomes the head of
the English church yeah within the
within the English church whoever hits
within the the yeah within may the
Anglican Communion the Archbishop of
Canterbury is is the top religious
official but the Archbishop of
Canterbury's chosen back down by the
king nowadays bye-bye who's in charge in
England's not the king engine or the
Queen Parliament I have the Prime
Minister so what you've got here is sort
of like taking part of the church and
saying you guys do whatever you're going
to do over there we're going to do our
thing here and they didn't actually
change anything in any important way
under Henry other than who's who's in
charge after Henry dies like your book
says well there was one of the important
thing that happens under a tree that I
should say you looked on those talk
about suppression
which means that they close the
monasteries and they send two moms home
and the monasteries now belong to the
king and the King can do it every lights
with them talking heads monasteries are
pretty nice places because monks tend to
be pretty industrious and they'd also
get a lot of donations and so the King
had a lot of wealth to spread around
there are still to this day a very few
Anglican Benedict ins but all the rest
of the orders have more or less
disappeared there's an Anglican
benedictions up the road by the way I'm
on the other side of the river so the
liturgy didn't change beliefs didn't
change doctrine didn't change it's only
with later people like Edward these
Edward the sick under emperor the safety
start seeing some changes and this guy
thomas cranmer the archbishop at that
time starts introducing a lot of new
practices because he's very impressed by
the process of reformation as it's going
on in germany as it's going on in france
as it's going on in switzerland so he
tries to revise the church's order of
worship and the addition of the first
edition of the book of common prayer
comes out of that we'll talk about that
why it's important in the moment they
did get married you guys might number is
bloody mary what was she called Bloody
Mary because there's like the mud a lot
anyone know yeah put to death yeah and
so you know the like any controversial
thing some some people yeah like
millions
gosh you didn't do anything the truth is
somewhere in the middle Mary trying to
bring England back to Catholicism and by
that time this this new Anglican thing
had become the going concern so a lot of
people said no that's not going to be
what we do and then you know they find
themselves murdered and now we get to be
fair the the Anglicans did plenty of
harboring themselves of Catholics and of
the independence there's a lot of blame
to throw around throughout the
Reformation lots of people did lots of
bad things to each other but Mary does
that and then put such a bad taste in
people's mouths this attempt to impose
Catholicism that force that when her
sister who we know was a very famous
mother Elizabeth comes on who reigned
for a very long time she brings it back
22 Anglicanism and her main concern is
to to make sure that there's peace in
the kingdom that England is safe from
these Catholic powers like France and
Spain at the time and that the church is
actually going to be a going concern I
could fall apart because another thing
that's happening under Elizabeth's reign
is the Puritans are coming to the floor
the Puritans are people who feel like
this anglican church has not purified
itself enough of all these but they
called Romish elements okay you know
traditional Catholic elements they
wanted to get rid of you know the
traditional manners they wanted to view
the sacraments as not as being
ordinances see them in a very different
way they wanted a different church
structure they certainly didn't want the
King in charge or the Queen in charge of
the church they thought that that was a
very bad idea so Elizabeth is trying to
like you know reconcile all these sides
and keep the Catholics from coming back
back in and taking over and your book
talks a little bit about the Puritans
but I'm going to skip over that
I want to talk about them in a later
chapter or its devoted to them one of
the off shots of this is that in these
discussions with the Puritans who were
saying Bible alone scripture alone the
Church of England said that you have
scripture we have tradition certainly
what a lot like like the Catholics now
right in the Eastern Orthodox and then
what was the third one for Roman
Catholics vegetarian for that for the
Anglicans reason three sources of three
equally legitimate sources figuring out
how one ought to live the Christian life
how the church ought to be organized who
ought to be in charge you know how far
they should go in there their reforms
they talk about another important king
who you who you probably have at least
heard of in terms of Scripture and
that's King James why is this guy
significant he's a Stuart King actually
spends a lot of time you know raised up
in Scotland the King James Bible that
english translation yeah it wasn't at
the time called the King James Bible it
was called the authorized version but
why was it you know call the King James
Bible he's a little water Isaac he got
together all these scripture scholars
and he said look we gotta have a
translational vibrant an anglican
translation vibrant why were they not
having a translation in english there
were other english translations around
why do you think they just didn't stick
with the other english translations any
guesses
yeah I didn't fit with what you were
trying to say like yeah it was very good
you know what I expected to be the first
response well they just work very good
translations and they need to be
improved but you're exactly right the
Puritans were appealing to what was
called the Geneva Bible you have the
Geneva Bible when you when you translate
Scripture you inevitably bring in some
of your presuppositions your your ways
of seeing things and the Geneva Bible
came from Geneva where it was all
calvinists and Calvinists and Anglicans
didn't really mix doctrinally so you
didn't want people going around saying
well look the Bible says this I'm
controversial points so they came out
with a Bible that in certain ways to put
the Anglican mold better the King James
Bible by the way of that one right here
it's a great work of literature it is it
is one of the most important works of
literature in english language you know
you can take it take a look at it you
might you might say oh I don't want to
read Shakespeare this is very different
than Shakespeare it's using older
English Shakespeare in order to like you
know fully grasp but he's talking about
you need to know something like they say
fifty thousand words not this this was
written in a very simple style now it
has stuff like spake instead of spoke
that's because that's the Indian list of
the time and it's very beautiful
language so I'll just you know pass it
around by the way there there's a book
if you're interested in knowing the
history of this which is called God's
secretaries it has a great history of
the process of translation so King James
Bible another I suppose we can if we
ramp with the King James Bible we should
also say the book of common prayer as
being something central yeah if you look
at the Book of Common Prayer you find
that it covers the liturgy it covers all
sorts of important things for angular
and communal life the order of the mass
there's actually a couple different
versions of it available now because
there have been some controversies or
splits over time and how it should be
updated and the Anglicans are in a
certain respect probably the closest to
the older churches they they you know
trace their succession back to the
Apostles and they think that that
matters they view the Eucharist as being
the real presence of Jesus it just like
you know Catholics and Orthodox and
Coptic Christians and all the way down
line view and as opposed to say
Lutheran's who recognize two sacraments
baptism and communion Anglican zar kind
of conflicted are there two sacraments
or other seven sacraments like like a
meal they actually here's a the way
Anglican is very often times all times
both just depends on how you look at
they took the book talks about the
middle way Anglican is quite often are
living within ahead of intentional
ambiguity about things now your book
talks about the Anglican Communion and
that's something that I should burn up
as well Anglicanism is you know you
could say that it's an ethnic church
just like Lutheranism to a large extent
is but the Lutheran's didn't do an awful
lot colonizing did they you know the
Swedes and Germans the British did
though didn't they where did the British
go to hear right who's the colony or sub
colonies where else where else with a
British like a major concern Africa yeah
and a lot of the Anglican churches that
are still growing today are in the
Africa where else where else diluted
yeah India
the British controlled India for a long
time interestingly they didn't do it
they didn't do it the Anglican didn't
make a lot of progress and India so
there are some Indian Anglican suppose
they got nothing like what happened in
the Africa you know the mass conversions
where else do you remember besides of
course canada australia australia was
more you know irish yeah right up well
little little tiny pockets but because
we know like the treaty cities thinking
about somewhere somewhere else i'll give
you a hint is spanish the official
language besides of course brazil
portuguese in all of North very all of
South and Central America or other some
is there is one place where English is
the official language that you can think
of some English colonization did take
place believes in other parts of South
America and like the African churches
these are these are growing churches the
weight of the Anglican Communion and
which by the way its kind of split in
recent times is swinging towards what we
call the third world you know Africa
South America normally we would include
Asian that there's not a ton of Asian
Anglicans so that's enough for the time
being about about the Anglicans against
this is sort of like keep it in your
pocket so you can use this information
later on as the story goes and gets more
and more complicated